una semana después del secuestro de este
orfanato en haití 17 miembros de un
grupo misionero norteamericano podrían
permanecer en cualquier parte de la isla
el pasado sábado 16 estadounidenses un
canadiense y su conductor haitiano
fueron secuestrados en el grupo hay
cinco niños incluyendo uno de ocho meses
estaban en ahí tiene una misión con los
ministerios de ayuda cristiana con sede
en ohio desde sus ciudades de origen las
familias se enviaron una carta
agradeciendo a la gente alrededor del
mundo por sus oraciones
siguen uniéndose y apoyándose con
oraciones y ánimo en estos momentos
difíciles es increíble como los tiempos
difíciles tienen una forma de unir a la
gente oremos por estas familias se
encuentran en una situación difícil
la declaración de la familia llega días
después de que se publicara un vídeo en
el que se ve al líder de la banda 400
abuso diciendo que matará a los rehenes
si no cumplen sus exigencias la banda
pide un millón de dólares por cada red
la secretaria de prensa a los eeuu dijo
que el fbi está trabajando con las
autoridades haitianas
y obviamente estamos trabajando sin
descanso para atraer a estas personas a
casa son ciudadanos estadounidenses y en
el transcurso de los últimos años se ha
atacado norteamericanos en haití tan
sólo este año se ha producido al menos
455 secuestros que son habituales en
haití donde la anarquía y la violencia
de las bandas está en aumento el jueves
cientos de haitianos cerraron un barrio
en puerto príncipe en protestas contra
el gobierno la creciente inseguridad de
haití las bandas bloquean la
distribución de gasolina y los
secuestros